[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 15 janvier
bienvenue pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce set 8 journal la
visite aujourd'hui d'agnès busin dans
les yvelines la ministre des solidarités
de la santé est venu parler de la lutte
contre la pauvreté des enfants et des
jeunes
un déplacement qui a débuté à plaisir
par une matinée d'échangés autour de la
petite enfance la sphère lactalis fait
scandale depuis plusieurs mois ces lots
de poudre de lait pour bébés contaminés
par des salmonelles
plus de 12 millions de boîtes sont
concernés d'après le patron du groupe
comment la grande distribution
gère-t-elle la crise reportage dans un
supermarché des yvelines et puis ils
sont frères et s'apprête à vivre une
grande aventure kevin et guillaume tora
devons partir pour trois ans de tour du
monde
un périple à vélo et en vidéo pour
promouvoir le partage et le respect de
l'environnement
un voyage de 80 mille ha km à travers 45
pays
et puis dans ce journal nous parlerons
également un basket avec une première à
moitié de saison réussie pour l'entente
le chesnay versailles c'est à suivre
dans ce journal est la grogne monte chez
les surveillants pénitentiaires après un
débrayage vendredi à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats les agents de la
maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy se sont de
nouveau mobilisés ce matin comme partout
en france
il réclame des mesures fortes après
l'agression à la prison de
vendin-le-vieil dans le pas de calais
trois gardiens pour rappel ont été
blessées jeudi par un détenu radicalisé
au moment d'une sortie de cellule est
les syndicats ont rencontré ce matin les
représentants du ministère de la justice
et de l'administration pénitentiaire et
non content de cet entretien il annonce
que le mouvement est reconductible
en france un enfant sur cinq vivraient
sous le seuil de pauvreté constat
alarmant pour les professionnels du
secteur de la petite enfance une
concertation avec ses acteurs a été
lancé par le président de la république
emmanuel macron ça c'était en octobre
dernier
aujourd'hui une première rencontre se
déroulait à plaisir en présence d'agnès
buzançais la ministre des solidarités et
de la santé un reportage de camille
lambert
représentant de la caisse d'allocations
familiales des yvelines de la
croix-rouge ou d'associations en faveur
des plus démunis
ce sont eux les premiers acteurs de la
lutte contre la pauvreté et notamment
celle des enfants en présence de la
ministre des solidarités de la santé ils
ont fait part de leurs connaissances et
de leurs attentes
on a toujours des attentes sur la
question de la parentalité de la petite
enfance
d'autant que c'est quand même le premier
pli à l'étrier je dirais sur le lien
social
c'est ce qui a été évoqué par madame la
ministre donc ça c'est déjà le premier
point de bien vous préciser que faire
société
ça passe aussi et surtout parler tout
petit dans la tente et pouvoir peut-être
participer à des groupes de travail
parce qu'on a fait que évoqué ce matin
le sujet et qu'il faut approfondir en
france un enfant sur cinq vivraient sous
le seuil de pauvreté
cette journée marquait la première d'une
série de concertations lancées par le
gouvernement en octobre 2010 cet
objectif établir une stratégie de lutte
contre la pauvreté des enfants
nous voyons qu'il va falloir intervenir
sur le repérage l'identification des
besoins sur l'accès aux droits sur la
formation des professionnels
ce que je ne
aussi c'est une mobilisation et un
engagement très fort des acteurs de
terrain avec énormément d'initiatives
locales
ça m'a permis de parler surtout des
dispositifs innovants en faveur des de
l'enfance notamment l'espace bébé
parents qui est un lieu d'échangé lieu
d'accueil
un dispositif que la croix-rouge
souhaitent développer en milieu rural
sous une forme itinérante une dizaine
d'autres rencontres de ce type sont
prévues partout en france
remise de la stratégie adoptée à l'issue
de ces réunions prévues fin mars au
président de la république
agnès buzyn qui a poursuivi à sa visite
cet après midi dans les yvelines la
ministre a participé à la pose de la
première pierre de l'extension à du
centre hospitalier poissy saint germain
en laye à nous y reviendrons dans notre
édition de demain soir et des lots de
lait infantile contaminées par des
salmonelles affaires lactalis sévit
depuis septembre dans une interview au
journal du dimanche le pdg de lactalis
emmanuel besnier promet d'indemniser les
victimes 12 millions de boîtes seraient
concernés et nous avons a voulu savoir
comment a été gérée à la crise dans les
yvelines
reportage auprès d'une grande
distribution avec nicolas landry 14h04
l'heure est au bilan dans ce supermarché
de fontenay-le-fleury romain et bertrand
de craie cogérant contre les produits
lactalis retirés des rayons et détruit
total de l'inventaire 99 boîte sur onze
référence des boîtes de lait en poudre
soupçonnés d'être contaminés à la
salmonelle des destructions suite aux
alertes envoyées par le fournisseur
depuis le 21 décembre dernier
tous les employés du magasin ont accès à
ces informations
je vais dessus et on avance et nier ce
qu'on avait nous en magasin le nombre du
vc et on a accusé bien sûr la
destruction des produits
on attend donc jusqu'au 21 janvier
non autour de nos clients pour savoir
s'il ya des clients qui ont acheté ce
produit est maintenant à savoir si dans
notre stock qu'on avait physiquement
magasin il y avait un risque microbien
ou pas de salmonelle sa relance est rien
et on n'a aucun moyen de savoir
l'approvisionnement des produits
lactalis a aussi été bloquées en clair
le magasin ne peut plus commander les
boîtes de lait concernés par la
contamination des informations aux
consommateurs sont aussi affichés à
l'accueil du magasin et dans le rayon à
l'emplacement habituel des produits
retirés
donc c'est tous les lots concernés qui
pourraient présenter un cas de
salmonelle voilà l'information qu'on a
mis dans une position du consommateur
donc on a un prix mais qu est la même
qu'on voit là ya l'accueil expliquant
donc la procédure à suivre pour le
consommateur qui auraient pu acheter
ce lait lactalis donc avant le 21
décembre mauvais étiquetage produits
défectueux plusieurs raisons pour
retirer ou détruire un produit en
moyenne ce magasin reçoit une alerte par
jour objectif éduquer à la préservation
de la nature yvelines environnement
vient de lancer son jeu concours annuel
à destination des 5 15 ans habitant ou
étant scolarisés dans le département nos
amis les prairies se déroule jusqu'au 7
avril 2018 pour y participer les jeunes
doivent remplir une grille de mots
croisés est illustrée par un dessin la
thématique les lauréats seront
récompensés au cours d'une cérémonie en
mai au palais des congrès de versailles
propos recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude
et on écoutera peut-être juste après
cette interview recueillie par patrick
jacques de dixmude précise que la date
de participation date limite de
participation c'est le 7 avril 2018 est
les documents du jeu concours sont à
retrouver dans toutes les gares sncf du
département ou sur internet sur le site
d'yvelines environnement d'environnement
justement on en parle encore avec
l'utilisation des eaux usées pour
chauffer une résidence étudiante
l'idée peut paraître étrange et pourtant
ce procédé très écologique est utilisé
dans plus de plus en plus de bâtiments à
guyancourt les étudiants de la résidence
andré de noyer de ségonzac bénéficie
depuis septembre dernier de ce système
qui est respectueux de l'environnement
sujet d'aurélie rond et nicolas
d'android tout ce volume ne grise un
cercle et douches les vieux donc de
l'eau froide avec de l'eau chaude mitigé
arrive dans cette grosse cuve en inox
voici le système installé au sous sol
d'une résidence étudiante à guyancourt
qui permet de bénéficier d'une eau
chaude développement durable ces
machines ont été mises au point par
l'entreprise de traitement des eaux
biofluides le principe c'est de
récupérer toute cette chaleur avant
qu'elles soient envoyées dans l'est dans
les égouts 1 et de la refroidir dans
quel impact environnemental
donc on m'a émissions de gaz à effet de
serre donc ça c'est la première des
choses le point le plus important est le
deuxième point c'est le sait l'économie
sur la facture d'eau chaude sanitaire
coût de l'installation pour cette
résidence 247 logements environ 200000
euros pour l'arpège l'association
spécialisée dans la gestion de
résidences pour étudiants ce dispositif
présente de nombreux avantages à
l'intérêt pour nous c'est de
réussir à l'heure des économies
d'énergie notamment de réduire les coûts
de ré chauffage de l'eau donc c'est
vraiment de qui payent le moins le moins
possible de charges en plus de ce
système qui réutilise les eaux usées
pour chauffer l'eau la résidence possède
plusieurs panneaux photovoltaïques des
démarches respectueuses de
l'environnement qui séduisent les
locataires je trouve ça super puisque
c'est vraiment des des problèmes
importants
côté environnemental con auquel on fait
face je fais également de plus
d'attention qu'ils avaient encore
notamment harmonisation chauffage
j'essaye aussi de d'éviter d'être 7
fronton sous la douche dans les
prochains mois une centaine d'immeubles
en france devrait être équipée de ce
système de valorisation des eaux usées
cinq rendez vous plus informelle au lieu
d'une grande seule cérémonie voisins le
bretonneux organise en ce moment ci
voeux pour la nouvelle année en se
déplaçant dans plusieurs quartiers
le premier rendez vous avait lieu il ya
quelques jours on centre-ville
l'occasion d'évoquer alliés projets
structurants pour 2018 avec notamment le
début des travaux pour le quartier de la
remise à terme 500 logements seront
construits qu'on écoute à ce propos le
maire de la commune au micro de nicolas
kirillovitch la remise est évidemment le
projet phare de la ville puisque c'est
un écoquartier que ça va accueillir un
certain nombre d'habitants nouveau et
puis on a voulu que ce soit quelque
chose de très qualitatif dont c'est vrai
que c'est un projet phare mais j'ai
également parlé d'un projet sur un
terrain qui saperaient de la manivelle
où il ya une résidence
intergénérationnelle pour les personnes
âgées et qu'ils partagent aussi leur
quotidien que des personnes plus
et puis j'ai parlé aussi d'un projet de
cimetière puisque notre cimetière est
vraiment maintenant arrivé à saturation
donc c'est une obligation et donc nous
travaillons ardemment à trouver un
emplacement pour un bras nouveau
cimetière
quatre-vingt mille kilomètres à travers
la planète 45 pays à traverser pour un
tour du monde qui va durer trois ans
voici le grand périple que vont
affronter à ces deux aventuriers
yvelinois ils sont frères et avec moi en
plateau guillaume et et kevin taurin
bonsoir concerne guillaume à ma droite
kévin à ma gauche merci d'être avec nous
alors c'est une grande aventure vous
allez faire à vélo on va en parler dans
un instant pourquoi avoir choisi le vélo
pour cette aventure
le départ est fixé pour le deuxième
trimestre 2010 8 petit tour de table
pour commencer qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé à vous lancer dans cette aventure
guillaume on va commencer avec vous on a
réalisé déjà plusieurs voyages à vélo
dans notre jeunesse des aventures on a
profité des vacances scolaires pour pour
voyager à travers l'europe
et de fil en aiguille on s'est dit on
pourrait faire un plus grand voyage on
s'intéressait à faire le tour de
l'europe et puis on s'est dit on a
peut-être qu'une occasion de faire un
grand grand voyage
donc on s'est lancé sur une idée de tour
du monde à vélo un grand voyage qui
s'appelle ebro j'ai oublié de le
préciser
kevin way guillaume était très bien vous
n'êtes pas à votre coup d'essai vous
avez fait déjà plusieurs voyages
notamment en 2011
un père et enfin un pèlerinage on peut
dire de paris à saint jacques de
compostelle exactement il était plus
spirituel religieux pour le coup mais on
a fait notre premier périple en 2011 sur
saint jacques de compostelle c'était
exceptionnel je pense que nous pour nous
c'est vraiment quelque chose à faire et
on encourage les personnes à le faire
c'est un sentier très très beau et puis
ensuite on est parti en suisse en
autriche en hongrie
on a fait aussi
d'autres pays dont l'espagne pourrait
jacques de composants pour good ce genre
d'aventuré je crois qu'on s'arrête plus
vraiment beaucoup parce qu'il ya aussi
un très très bel échange d'aventuriers
pendant pendant les différents périples
et je pense qu'on a pris goût à ça tout
simplement
alors il ya plusieurs buts dans ce
voyage partagé bien sûr votre passion
pour pour l' aventure mais il ya aussi
une idée derrière c'est sensibiliser
autour du respect de l'environnement et
tout ça vous allez le faire pour ce
voyage vous avez tourné des vidéos tout
au long de ce voyage en trois ans tout à
fait l'idée de ce projet c'est comme
vous l'avez dit c'est vraiment de
sensibiliser les gens en voyage parce
que on parle de nous on considère en
fait que le voyage vous avez énormément
ouvert l'esprit et je pense que il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui peuvent qui
peuvent en témoigner
donc pendant tout le périple où pendant
trois ans on a du matériel audiovisuel
professionnel qu'on emporte avec nous
pour faire des petites capsules vidéo
dédiée dans un premier temps au web
internet youtube d'accord et dans un
second temps on va filmer aussi pour
réaliser un documentaire de 52 minutes
qui sera destinée à l'aide à la télé ou
qui va reprendre en fait ces grands
principes le voyage le vélo et l'aspect
humain qu'on rencontre pendant l'
aventure dans le seul but de vouloir
réaliser ses rêves nous donner les
moyens d'y arriver
voilà tout simplement dû au moins dans
cette actualité où on parle souvent de
respect de l'environnement de hausse du
climat et cetera l'important est d'avoir
ce but derrière dans ce voyage c'était
quelque chose d'important à faire que ce
voyage mais aussi co de le faire dans un
but précis
or il est tout à fait c'est de vivre
simplement pour ça qu'on a choisi le
vélo qu'elle son côté
pratique économique écologique et de
nous de se rapprocher au plus près de la
terre et de ses habitants pour ensemble
partager des moments simples et nous
derrière de montrer de véhiculer et sur
la durée 3 ans pourquoi être parti sur
une durée si l'on vous l'avez dit vous
avez fait des voyages un peu plus
couillon là pourquoi partir sur une
durée aussi longue c'est un calcul qu'on
a fait par rapport donc on a
mis sur le papier tous les pays qu'on
voulait traverser et on a donc pris un
calcul théorique qui nous rapprochait
plus de trois ans d'accord en tout cas
on se dit pas plus pour qu'on va pour
retrouver notre famille ces avions aussi
ça peut être difficile trois ans loin de
ses amis loin de sa famille sur la
forcément regard a pas d'étape à paris
pour les revoir ces trois ans sans
avenir si guillaume tell il est
théoriquement non on l'espère l'objectif
c'est vraiment de faire faire le tour
sans qu'ils aient d'escale sur paris en
effet trois ans s'est fait partie des
grosses contraintes qu'on évoquera
pendant d'ailleurs le voyage parce que
c'est sûr que ça va être dur vraiment un
de ses proches loin de sa famille c'est
quelque chose qui est déjà difficile à
se préparer donc je suppose que pendant
le voyage savait assez compliqué
contraintes vous l'avez dit vous allez
faire le périple à vélo il y aura du
matériel audiovisuel sur une durée assez
longue il ya une grosse réflexion sur le
chargement qu'on va emporter avec soi ça
j'imagine que c'est ça a été quelque
chose aussi de réfléchi c'est quelque
chose de calculé on est on est au près
ce programme devrait en disons centaines
de grammes près on essaie d'optimiser le
point puisque c'est vrai qu'on se
trimballe tout ça et le fait de le faire
avec du matériel audiovisuel n'arrange
pas les choses parce que ça nécessite la
caméra un ordinateur forcément des
choses lourdes ils ont pas fait ça est
très léger les batteries rien que ça
c'est pas son point d'accord alors
chacun son rôle bon je vais aura son
rôle pendant ce voyage ne pas faire un
raccourci mais en gros kevin vous serez
plus avec la caméra à la main et
guillaume vous c'est plus la carte ses
fûts ce serait le guide à travers ce
voyage c'est ça c'est ça oui oui
le bon évidemment on a obligé de se
partager les tâches puis même le no no
vie ont fait que kevin s'est beaucoup
orienté sur la caméra appui même mois
cependant nos différents voyages j'étais
avec la carte on va choisir les bonnes
directions
donc on va fonctionner comme ça pendant
le voyage
puis aussi le soir on a les petits
rituels exemple à chacun prépare que ce
soit à manger ou l'emplacement où dormir
oui ça nous fait gagner du temps et ça
permet de bomba de de travailler en
équipe justement dormir vous parlez
dormir vous avez camper j'imagine aussi
dormir dans des auberges peut-être chez
l'habitant c'est l'idée oui mais tout à
fait il y alors quand on n'a rien trouvé
qu'on est au milieu d'une forêt bon
dormir dans la forêt mais le but c'est
quand même d'aller chez l'habitant
ce qu'on veut partager quand on est dans
un autre pays leur manière de vivre et
puis aussi vont pouvoir nous
nous quitter le lendemain sur un chemin
qui pourrait nous plaire ou qui est
important à traverser on va peut-être
voir la carte sais pas si on l'a encore
vu mais la carte avec ses 45 pays
traversés les grandes étapes en quelques
mots sur ce sur ce parcours de trois ans
dans un premier temps la direction de
l'afrique jusqu'à dakar en suivant
reprenant en fait les sentiers de saint
jacques de compostelle
ensuite on va attaquer sur l'amérique du
sud on va remonter progressivement
d'amérique du nord ont fait l'australie
ouais une partie de l'asie et on repart
ensuite en europe en suivant les
sentiers bien connus qui sont les héros
vélo au rythme de 10 jours de
deux périples un jour de retrouvailles à
chaque fois c'est ça sur cette moyenne
là on verra en fonction des conditions
climatiques mais théoriquement ça
devrait ça devrait se faire comme ça
puisque ça s'est toujours fait comme ça
en fait pour nous reste que quelques
minutes pour parler du budget il est
conséquent du budget prévisionnel de
60000 euros
enfin jeudi conséquent on se dit pour o2
ça fait à peu près 8 euros par jour on
se dit c'est sur trois ans apparaît peu
c'est peu en fait ça c'est clair c'est
pour ça que bombela sa part et c'est
vrai c'est assez conséquent 60000 euros
mais il ya ces fameux 8 euros par jour
qu'on a calculé sur des moyennes de qui
sont enfin les retours qui ont été faits
de certains voyageurs et ensuite il ya
les vélos il ya l'aspect audiovisuelle
qui coûtait très cher et
et plein de transport si toutefois on
est amené à utiliser le transport
tous ces petites choses finalement le
cumul fait que on arrive vite à 80000
euros
mille soixante mille pardons dernière
choisit le reste très peu de temps 20000
euros d'apport personnel c'est ça là on
en est où concrètement et comment
atteindre finalement ce palier des 60000
comment vous y comptait y parvenir des
sponsors peut-être des opérations à
venir tout à fait on est il ya des
opérations qui lui qui vont venir
puisqu'on a lancé la com début janvier
actuellement nous nous sommes suivis par
4 5 partenaires dont un partenaire
financier donc qui va nous aider
énormément sur sur le voyage et puis on
espère que il y en a plein d'autres qui
vont nous suivre et on va suivre ça a
vécu avec attention ce retrait et 78
merci à vous deux à guillaume et et
kevin tu auras d'avoir été avec nous
votre aventure est libre où elle peut se
suivre sur ce site internet et si vous
souhaitez souhaitez contribuer à leur
aventure peut apporter votre aide aux
projets rendez vous sur ce site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran un
exploit sportif on jouait ce week-end
les 32e de finale de la coupe de france
de handball trappe qui évolue en
excellence départementale recevait
samedi argenteuil une équipe de
prérégion et malgré sept divisions
d'écart
elie trappistes se sont qualifié sans
forcer pour le tour suivant
score final 34 à 25 le résumé de la
rencontre nicolas landry et michael et
demi d'euros
une qualification historique trappe une
équipe profonde en 2014 va accéder aux
seizièmes de finale de la coupe de
france après sa victoire 34 à 25 contre
argenteuil résultats acquis en première
période les trappistes comptait six buts
d'avancé à la mi temps
franchement aujourd'hui ça a été fait
dès la première mi temps parce que pour
nous on s'est préparé ce match là on a
tout donné dans les dix premières
minutes et on a fait la différence dès
le début donc on a senti que c'était pas
si l'après pour le bon on a tendance à
dire que les dix premières minutes de
chaque mi temps
c'est là où se fait la différence et les
joueurs ont répondu présent donc là
c'était en tant que coach
l'aspect parfait pour continuer son
épopée trèbes s'est appuyé pendant la
partie sur une grosse activité offensive
avec des gestes spectaculaires en
première période
autre point fort de l'équipe sur ce
match la défense les trappistes ce n'ont
concédé que 25 buts face à argenteuil
une formation qui évolue pourtant une
division au dessus des trappistes de
gouverner on prenait une trentaine de
buts 32 buts par match et on a fait un
gros travail de défense saab ont préparé
ce match donc l'objectif a été rempli
qu'on est en défense faut être agressif
fort il faut montrer qu'on est présent
sur le terrain donc on l'a montré en
défense on a essayé de monter de la
barre rapidement pour
voilà pour prendre avantage une
combativité qu'il faudra conserver au
tour suivant trap est désormais le petit
poucet d'île de france et qui pourrait
affronter pendant les finales régionales
baudoux semaines-- s'il brille sur vingt
trois équipes de prérégion la rencontre
soit programmé le week-end du 18 février
mais en attendant le club peut savourer
mais 10 matches 10 victoires et une
première place pour le moment en
régionale 2 de basket une première
moitié de saison réussi pour l'équipe
première masculine de l'entente le
chesnay versailles pour en parler avec
moi sur ce plateau 2 invité olivier
patins bonsoir vous êtes l'entraîneur de
l'équipe première masculine le
chesnay-versailles tu es également avec
moi yoann abraham vous êtes l'ailier
fort de cette équipe première du chesnay
versailles
alors on va regarder peut-être le
classement de cette régionale de la
poule b vous êtes prêts pour le moment
premier avec deux points d'avancé sur
vos principal poursuivant on est presque
à la mi saison il reste un match pour
qu'on atteigne vraiment cette mi-saison
est ce que vous êtes totalement
satisfait olivier de cette première
partie de saison pour le chesnay
versailles a bien évidemment on réalise
une très très bonne première partie de
saison on met des concurrents directs
derrière puisqu'on et on les a battus
chez eux
donc du coup on va avoir le luxe de
pouvoir les recevoir sur le match retour
donc oui on peut être que satisfait
après 10 matches 10 victoires en
championnat rien à redire
je précise que vous êtes l'entraîneur de
l'équipe depuis cette saison tout comme
yoann qui a rejoint l'effectif
cette année comment vous vous sentez au
sein de cet effectif très très bien
honnêtement j'ai l'impression de
connaître la plupart des joueurs depuis
un petit moment alors que on se connaît
depuis quelques mois enfin on ressent
vraiment sur le terrain c'est voilà
c'est une bonne osmose
je me sens vraiment très très bien
l'effectif de cette saison et c'était
des points forts des joueurs forts qui
était déjà au club avec quelques
nouveautés johan pour la partie terrain
et vous sur la partie basse et ça c'est
ce knicks on va dire qui fait la
réussite de cette première partie avant
c'est exactement ça en fait le but
c'était vraiment de garder l'ossature de
cette équipe où il y avait déjà de très
bons éléments
voilà le
le club a relancé le projet masculin ou
en tout cas nous a bien fait comprendre
que c'était important pour eux de
remonter jusqu en nationale 3 au moins
est assez vite et donc voilà où avec ma
venue et la venue de certains joueurs le
but était surtout de garder 7,7 cette
osmose comme l'a dit johan et c'est ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui ça marche plutôt
bien
est ce que le club est en nationale iii
précisant saison la saison lors de la
saison 2014-2015 de descendre d'affilée
une montée montier l'an passé le
discours en début de saison quand on
arrive à la tête de l'équipe c'est ça
était quoi votre discours le discours il
a été qu'il fallait se relever déjà
parce que c'est pas évident de rater
lors de la dernière journée sur un sur
un match seulement puisque le vainqueur
du dernier match de leur saison montée
en prénationale donc ça a été le cas
pour pour me dont et puis ça a été aussi
enfin un peu plus particulier pour moi
puisque j'étais déjà dans cette poule
entraîneur d'arcueil et c'est nous qui
sommes montés avec meudon en
prénationale pour me retrouver ensuite
la versa est donc le discours a été
simple c'est qu'il fallait se relever et
il fallait se remettre au travail tout
de suite et ne pas tergiverser
et puis et puis ben ils l'ont fait et de
la plus belle des manières première
moitié de saison réussie en championnat
c'est également le cas en coupe avec ce
très beau résultat vous avez atteint les
32e de finale de la coupe de france face
aux espoirs de châlons reims vous avez
été proche de l'exploit une défaite à
domicile 80 83 dans les toutes dernières
secondes yoann fier du parcours accompli
ou quand même type frustration parce que
ça s'est joué dans les toutes dernières
secondes du match
bon c'est sûr comme un combat comme une
certaine frustration c'est sûr et
certain mais après
on a réalisé comme un bon parcours est
pour pour notre part notre catégorie
on a en a on a su prouver à plusieurs
personnes et qu'on avait le niveau pour
se bagarrer justement contre des grosses
de curée contre les équipes de n2 ou
contre les crimes de m 3 dans l'ensemble
enfin voilà on a fait un beau parcours
c'est surtout renom discuter tout à
l'heure avec olivier plus si on avait
gagné contre chalon et c'est enfin soir
étaient des matchs en plus donc que
n'étant pas professionnel mettons enfin
donné mais n'ayant pas une structure
professionnelle
c'est un peu plus compliqué de justement
de tenir le rythme d'avant je voulais
finalement sur exact de l'émission
d'ailleurs mais on peut dire il ya pas
eu de gueule de bois après cette
élimination ce que là ce week-end vous
avez remporté votre match donc vous êtes
tout de suite remis tout est au travail
ben je pense qu'on avait surtout à coeur
de retrouver la victoire qu'on va
surtout on avait on est vraiment envie
de
de passer à autre chose parce que c'est
vrai que cette ville est défaite pardon
nous à nous à nous a mis 1 comme un
grand coup de manhattan à tête parce que
perdre deux points au buzzer français ça
arrive pas très couramment comme on a pu
le dire mais enfin ça arrive
malheureusement et c'est tombé sur nous
très rapidement olivier dernier mot là
on à la mi-saison première moitié de
saison réussi
quel e quelles vont être vos mots là
pour continuer de mobiliser vos joueurs
là jusqu'à la fin de saison l'objectif
principal c'est ça reste la montée à
rester la montée quoi qu'il arrive mal
et malgré cette parenthèse coupe de
france qui a été vraiment une belle
aventure
on s'est remis tout de suite au travail
pour ne pas pour ne pas se mettre en
difficulté parce que les deux
concurrents sont à deux défaites de nous
donc ça nous laisse une petite marge
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut encore les
rencontrer au match retour
et voilà l'objectif c'est d'essayer de
rester invaincu le plus longtemps
possible
si on peut le faire toute la saison ça
sera ça sera magnifique et et d'essayer
d'aller jouer une finale régionale pour
aller pour aller chercher le titre de
reginald mais merci à vous d'avoir été
avec nous en tout cas on va suivre la
suite de cette saison pour le
chesnay-versailles vous pouvez suivre en
tout cas les résultats l'actualité du
club sur le site internet qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran
une bonne nouvelle avant de refermer ce
journal le jeune joseph a été retrouvée
l'adolescent de 14 ans a été confié à
une famille d'accueil à nice en
attendant de pouvoir rejoindre sa tante
chez qui il habite aux clayes-sous-bois
sa disparition inquiétante rappelez-vous
avait été signalée le 19 décembre
arrivé depuis le cameroun cet été joseph
aurait fugué à cause d'une mésentente
avec ses proches
il avait trouvé dernièrement refuge à
rome en italie avant de revenir en
france
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal il est
disponible en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile la
tv 78 belle soirée excellente semaine à
tous
[Musique]